[Music]  the survival to the skies is at stake  that can be no peace the people are  desperate for justice there are some of  us who believe we can take our country  back  if we can unify and rise out behind one  leader  perhaps you  you are my family I cannot do this  without you  powers making decisions whatever course  you are charting I choose you  my husband Robert the Bruce to be  declared an outlaw  brother Bruce joy yourself real  is it true you're the king of scotch who  tell all your friends were going to our  country back  I have fifty men to hide the strongest  anymore  we're dealing with our girls man that K  will hang him for treason  if I died tomorrow let's die tomorrow do  whatever you must genders that  I wear this crown as a symbol of my duty  to serve the Scottish people  hi I'm King of Scots  north of the land with other people  we could fight for God  what country  bubbly  you don't care so long as you buy  [Music]  you  [Music]